hi there steve here today
i want to talk about speaking
because i always talk about input and
listening and reading so today i'm going
to talk about speaking remember if you
enjoy these videos give me a like or
this for this one and subscribe of
course
um so why do i want to talk about
speaking well first of all
in a previous video i said that i was
in a restaurant with this chinese couple
chinese friend of mine
who
goes to class every day in it to learn
english here in vancouver three hours a
day five days a week and he still
can't really speak very well and we
start speaking in english and he
switches back to chinese
so i mentioned that that i mentioned the
fact that as i'm leaving the restaurant
there was a table of iranians and i
struggled to say anything in persian
although
you know i know i can say things in
persian i just i froze couldn't say
anything
and explained almost as an excuse that
i've been learning turkish so there upon
one of them said i speak turkish what
can you say in turkish and i couldn't
say anything either
so
someone commented here on my on the
comments below my that video
sort of saying well steve you spent so
much time
learning a persian and
you can't say anything
and he said that he after
um
one or two weeks can speak cambodian and
all these other asian languages so
what's the matter with you
so
the issue of speaking obviously if your
goal is to be able to say something as
soon as possible
you can do that you can within a couple
of weeks say something
[Applause]
it has been my experience that you can't
say very much and you don't understand
very much of what comes back at you so
to me the issue always is not so much
what can i say after a week or two is
what can i say after six months or a
year in other words can i engage in a
meaningful conversation with people
where i understand a wide variety of
subjects potentially i have a lot of
words that i can draw on i may not find
them all when i need them but
potentially i can get to where i can
engage in meaningful conversations
that's my goal so therefore what i can
say
after three months after two weeks is
not so important to me
second of all i do get criticized you
know why do you spend you know x amount
of time on arabic and then next thing
you're doing persian and then you're
doing
turkish uh and then you can't speak
persian when you're suddenly challenged
to say something in persian
but this is another thing my sort of
input-based learning
is
basically creating the potential to be
able to speak meaningfully
everything that i have done in arabic
and persian is with me i haven't lost
that not only do i have it somewhere in
my brain but furthermore
i have it in all of my content at link
in all of my many stories which i can go
back to it that
almost represents sort of like an
external
hard drive
where i park things
that are part of my learning process
that i can go back to very quickly
refresh and improve on it's part of all
of the sort of
potential in the language that i have
invested in you have to invest up front
in the ability to speak well in the long
run now
eventually
to speak well you have to speak a lot so
if my chinese friend goes to language
class and never speaks doesn't even take
advantage of the opportunity of speaking
with me he's not going to improve to
speak well you have to speak a lot
eventually
if you are worried about how you sound
if you are worried about your mistakes
you won't speak a lot you have to work
your way through
that period where you are making
mistakes and you are doubting yourself
and you just have to go with it all
right but obviously you want to build up
sort of a sort of that that background
in the language so that you have a
chance of understanding
what people are saying and yet you have
a chance of finding words and phrases so
to summarize to speak well you have to
speak a lot my chinese friend my only
advice to him is you probably have
enough words to speak so start speaking
at every opportunity
second of all
what you can say after 10 days or two
weeks or three months is not as
important as what you will be able to
say
in the long run so
i am convinced that in my
three languages that i'm exploring right
now
arabic turkish and um
persian that are all connected
historically culturally that i'm going
to be involved with for
three years perhaps
i have the goal of being able to
read and listen and engage people in
conversations on a variety of subjects
in these three languages as my ultimate
goal so i don't really care that much if
in some random encounter in a restaurant
i struggle to say something so
short-term versus long-term
the
sort of fundamental activity in order to
get that language in you is still
listening and reading however comes a
point where if you want to improve your
speaking you're going to have to speak a
lot you're going to have accept the fact
that sometimes you'll be
tongue-tied and at other times
you'll be able to say more and you just
got to fight your way through it and
keep talking i hope that makes sense by
the way i still not sure where i'm
supposed to look in this my iphone to
make sure that i show up in the middle
of the screen we'll see what happens on
this one
uh what else was i going to say oh yeah
one other thing
i will have my first turkish
conversation tomorrow with a tutor here
at link
one of the content items that i was
using
at link is some tutor reports
with sort of reinhardt one of our link
members speaking to his turkey tutor
and they talk about a variety of things
that relate to reinhardt's experience as
a teacher in austria
i found these very good because it's
interesting to eavesdrop on reinhardt
and his conversation with his tutor
the
content consists of
full sentences and full phrases
the voice of the turkish
narrator is extremely pleasant to listen
to
i find this very useful learning content
for beginners
and i'd be interested in reactions from
people if i were to and in fact i can
put up my uh tutor conversations with my
persian tutors because we don't have a
lot of content for persian i wonder if
people would find these interesting i
would like to hear more of this kind of
material for turkish because i'm still
at a very early stage in my turkish and
this kind of you know variety
is great so that the the mini stories
are great because there's a lot of
repetition but
having a chance to peek into reinhardt's
conversation with his tutor is
interesting to me it introduces variety
and he
the the words and phrases that she reads
are the
words and phrases that i want to be able
to use in my conversation tomorrow with
my tutor
look forward to react to your reactions
bye for now
you